now turning our attention overseas
tonight a lot of crises around the world
biden uh that whole team continues to
resort to tired political platitudes
rather than confronting what are real
growing threats china iran russia biden
told putin on sunday that the u.s will
quote act decisively if the russian
leader invades ukraine i'm sure he's
shaking in his boots ask yourself does
anyone really think vladimir putin cares
what joe biden thinks does he not know
he's a cognitive mess yes he does and
get this the biden state department is
being mocked tonight after a bizarre
series of tweets about secretary of
state tony blinken's spotify
playlist his music playlist have you
heard the news secretary blinken is now
on spotify check out the latest
recommended playlist the department
tweeted i'll ask amid growing threats
around the world real threats the globe
can this be the priority of our state
department putin president xi kim
jong-un the muellers and iran they see
what the rest of us are seeing an
administration totally incapable or
unwilling to stand up to america's
adversaries and the threats are only
intensifying look at the new report from
the wall street journal detailing
increasing cooperation with china and
russia and by the way that also includes
iran detailing ambitious joint military
exercises deep collaboration on advanced
weapons technology and over in tyron
well the iranian president continues to
lash out and stoke wider kind of
conflict claiming former president trump
mike pompeo they've got to face trial
for taking out solamani or tehran will
seek revenge by the way today's the
anniversary of his death good riddance
to that evil terrorist and the
anniversary of president trump making
the decisive military decision to keep
america and the world safe here with
reaction former secretary of state fox
news contributor mike pompeo
i wish i knew the story behind this
because
the fact that you were able to nail this
guy is on a commercial flight you knew
he's on that flight and you wait for
everybody else to be safe every private
citizen you take them right out on the
tarmac one of the best military efforts
in our lifetime
sean happy new year to you you you went
around the world and the threats pretty
uh pretty accurately there sadly uh
you're right about these threats from
iran they're unprecedented you have a
nation state the world's largest state
sponsor terror very capable saying that
they're going to arouse every muslim in
the world to martyr president trump and
me uh that's uh that's something that's
not been done before it's a real
security risk and i think it tells you
something about how they're thinking
about this administration
we i wouldn't change a thing about what
we recommended to the president
we were defending the united states of
america we were keeping american people
safe qasim suleimani was actively
engaged in plotting against america and
we took military actions lawful military
action to make sure that no americans
were killed it was a good decision
and now we have the responsibility the
american leadership has a responsibility
sure and keep every american safe
against the threat from iran and to see
to see president rajisi out there
talking about putting president trump
and me on trial and then if that doesn't
work having us assassinated is deeply
unprecedented and a real responsibility
for the leadership team well it's a real
threat to your personal safety and
president trump's personal safety
i would take that seriously but i don't
think vladimir putin is amassing 200 000
troops on the ukrainian border for no
reason at all nor do i think that the
the sabre rattling and flying fighter
jets over taiwan airspace
is
is more than a message from china after
the olympics my prediction is is they
will try their quote reunification with
china am i wrong
sean i think that's likely
it's absolutely the case these are all
connected as well they're connected by
the central thesis of an administration
that's not prepared to defend the things
that matter most to america america's
security we demonstrated for four years
how deterrents work right ronald reagan
knew peace through strength we talked
about america first and getting it right
we made clear to the chinese we would
impose real costs with them
i don't think vladimir putin would have
behaved in the way he's behaving today
coercing europe coercing the west
having conversations with the president
united states walking away thinking i
think i'll send a few more troops to the
ukrainian border remember this is a
president who chose not to send military
assistance to the ukrainians when they
took one-fifth of ukraine i suspect
vladimir putin thinks that the things
that biden is telling him today are not
likely to be followed through on i hope
he's wrong i hope president biden is
determined to protect america's
interests wherever they are
i suspect that leaders around the world
don't see that they saw what happened in
afghanistan they saw a pipeline shut
down in southern southeast part of the
united states and we did virtually
nothing i hope this administration will
begin to restore the deterrence that
america had these past four years it
kept a lot of us safe
if i'm right and we have this
it's not that i'm right we know that
there is this new alliance with china
and russia and but it also includes iran
which makes me the most nervous because
if you marry
radical islam
with weapons of mass destruction
and convert and a convert or die
philosophy
that could only lead to one thing
potentially even a modern-day holocaust
a danger that the world better never
ever have to face but i'm afraid more
every day that in fact we're headed in
that direction
thoughts
the weaker america is the more
appeasement we show going to the
negotiating table even as we speak sean
going to the negotiating table in vienna
to talk to the iranians about striking a
deal to get back in the
the cruddy deal that we had in the jcpoa
the nuclear deal uh that's the kind of
appeasement that creates the very risk
that you talk about i assure you the
israelis are concerned about that as
well they're concerned about iran
getting a nuclear weapon on president
biden's watch they know that american
weakness
puts real risk on israel real risk that
you could have some kind of holocaust
and we shouldn't forget sean too add
venezuela and cuba into that mix with
china iran and russia and you've got
real risk right here in our hemisphere
right 90 miles off of america's shore
we need to do the things that the trump
administration did to protect america i
hope this administration will begin to
show that kind of real resolve and
strength yeah well the world sees that
joe biden is weak and they're obviously
taking advantage of it and that deal
that iranian deal that that
brought paint plane loads cargo plane
loads of cash and other currency for the
mueller's and iran uh would also allow
them to get nuclear weapons by 2025
anyway the worst deal in history uh mr
secretary happy new year thank you for
being with us
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else